i'm kennedy i'm bill hemmer i'm sandra
smith and this is the fox news rundown
wednesday june 22nd 2022
i'm dave anthony
he was a doctor trying to heal on tv
now he's a candidate trying to win in
pennsylvania i think i speak for a lot
of americans who are woken up one too
many days with the sense that there's
anxiety in the country that's
addressable and so i'm gonna do
everything i can to help we speak with
republican senate nominee mehmet oz
i'm jessica rosenthal the southwest is
literally running out of water and
federal officials say they may have to
step in if people don't start reducing
water use on their own we're reaching
the breaking point in our ability to use
water and sustain our communities here
in the whole southwestern united states
and i'm colin reed i've got the final
word in the fox news rundown
we're still in the middle of primary
season setting up the 2022 race for
congress that republicans hope ends with
them in power again if we are able to
win a majority that's how we're able to
govern house gop leader kevin mccarthy
told fox business if we were fortunate
enough to win 35 republican seats that
would be the largest republican majority
in more than 100 years but the 50-50
senate could go either way
one big target for democrats
pennsylvania hoping to replace retiring
republican senator pat toomey john
fetterman is their candidate but the
lieutenant governor has been campaigned
since right before winning the primary
when he suffered a stroke saying back in
may with his wife giselle by his side it
was on friday i just wasn't feeling very
well so i decided you know what i need
to get checked out so i went to the
hospital
because i was right as always now he is
still in the race as he recovers and
ahead in a new poll of dr mehmed oz the
republican nominee
it sounds nice but it actually is a lot
nicer because in the and i was warned
about this in the primary it's basically
character assassination dr oz won the
primary after a recount you're going up
against people you agree with generally
right you have to argue that you're a
better person and carry the ban or carry
the message in the general election
which is we're in now i get to talk
about policies i could talk about
legislative issues i get to talk about
things that are really bothering
americans day in and day out and these
topics we'll get to in the interview but
they're ones that immediately attract
everyone's attention so it's less like
being in fifth grade okay and more like
more like being in high school all right
so you've graduated
is it is it
like i do a breathasi release is it
easier does it feel different do you
feel more comfortable now it's not that
it's easier it is more comfortable it's
what i wanted to do that's why i went
into the arena of politics i spent my
whole life as you speaking to people
trying to connect uh making sure the
stories that i'm sharing with them
elevated them bringing guests into their
lives they could
get them to think differently about
opportunities and challenges and in the
political world you at least i want to
do the same thing i'm a heel i'm a
doctor so my goal has always been to
empower people to get them to challenge
authority when it made sense to empower
themselves with information and when
you're running in a general election in
particularly in a time like this when
there's such clear differences between
the far right and the far left and
there's a lot of room in the middle to
help people uh it's tailor-made for
someone like me and so i enjoy it a lot
i get up in the morning and i don't have
to memorize my lines i know exactly what
games i think are important in the lives
of people i'm trying to help and i can
go hard on those topics and it works for
that reason how hard is it though after
that fight with those other republicans
to try to get them on board with you
absolutely essential and it has been
much easier than i expected i really
thought there'd be hard feelings or
folks who are reluctant take some time i
mean david mccormick lost by less than a
thousand votes that's very close and
imagine being that situation yet he was
gracious in his concession he's a
professional
he has a future i think
just about anything he wants to do but
the ability for him to bounce back from
that and to make it clear to everybody
in pennsylvania that the battle happened
we fought
hard but it's over and now we got to
unify around one candidate first of all
means the world to me and my effort but
it also means a lot to pennsylvanians
because he put their interests above his
own um and you know he endorsed me but
he also contributed financially which is
an important additional step which he
recognized would symbolize to everybody
it's time to stop what happened in the
primary and move forward jeff bartos who
also was one of my fierce competitors is
one of my campaign co-chairs carlos
ambassador sans carlos sainz uh present
events with me so it has allowed the
party to heal and when you spend a lot
of money hitting each other it hurts you
leave scars but like siblings if you can
make up your your bonds would have been
stronger because we were forged in the
same furnace and now we are laser
focused on what is a true i think clear
and present danger in pennsylvania but
also to our nation which is a candidate
john fetterman who's far to the left of
joe biden remember joe biden grew up in
scranton he's a pennsylvania yeah until
more of a blue collar or old-fashioned
democrat the people have said he used to
be i mean he's moved clearly far to the
left of of what he thought he would be
and what we all thought he would be uh
and that's sent a clear message to a lot
a chilling message to a lot of democrats
in pennsylvania so you say john
fetterman is farther left more bernie
sanders like in fact bernie sanders is a
specific example he endorsed bernie
sanders in 2016. he called bernie
sanders together with him the two most
progressive candidates in america he's
endorsed uh you know socialized medicine
uh you know where you to get rid of
private insurance it's not something
pennsylvanians want but he's also done
other things along the way uh like
arguing for more spending uh which in
this case the reckless spending as you
know is worse than our inflation but it
also represents that you're not willing
to make the harsh decisions you're not
willing to own up to the reality that
you can't just throw money at a lot of
these far left social programs you
actually have to have a game plan and
you have to have an agenda for
prosperity but most importantly in
pennsylvania he's taking his stance
against energy which for the entire
country i think is a mistake because you
it hurts our energy autonomy it hurts us
in international relations and hurts our
ability to maintain national security
all right and it infuriates
pennsylvanians enough so they'll vote
republican even conservative democrats
who again culturally are democrats these
are jfk democrats
from wilkes-barre scranton where joe
biden is from for example they're going
to vote for me on the republican ticket
this year and they may stay republican
because they're so frustrated by how far
left the democratic party has been
pulled they're not against the
democratic party they're they're against
the far left elements of the party that
don't seem to honestly be able to debate
these issues okay but you mentioned john
fetterman your democratic opponent he's
lieutenant governor
new usa today suffolk poll which i'm
sure you saw he has a nine point lead
over you
and in that same poll it listed your
unfavorability at 50 percent
so what do you have to do to change
minds what what message do you have to
do to sell yourself
well in medicine you learn about
tincture of time sometimes the patient's
going to heal just fine on their own
after having had 40 million dollars
dumped on my head of negative
advertising
it does tend to drive up your
unfavorables all right and it also
divided the party so the poll was done
literally as soon as the
secretary of state confirmed that i was
the candidate and not surprisingly a lot
of republicans haven't healed yet from a
contentious primary so that's going to
happen naturally right ten percent of
them i think we're supporting fetterman
yeah more twenty percent okay so you
have to get their minds back and changed
right and that's going to it's going to
happen naturally especially as democrats
attack me which there they are now i
have two goals right now make sure that
conservatives whether the democrats
republicans understand my family values
or their family values and we have to
govern from those values
and i have to remind them that joe biden
has lurched to the left in part because
he doesn't believe in the innovativeness
of americans he doesn't believe in the
grit that we have and if you don't
believe in the innovativeness and the
ingenuity of americans then you don't
believe in america and when you have a
candidate running opposite me who's
further to the left of joe biden it
reminds them that this is not a path
we're happy with the you know 75 of
pennsylvanians do not like where this
country's headed so they want change
who's the candidate of change who's the
outsider it's me john federman is the
insider candidate who's already
established himself as being as one
who's willing to [ __ ] pennsylvania
businesses which they have done and his
lieutenant governor he helped lead that
charge he wants to release one-third of
all prisoners from our uh for know
inmates which is in a time of of turmoil
where we have a crisis of of safe
streets in philadelphia the biggest
murder spree ever in this in this in the
city's history why are you releasing one
third of prisoners and arguing against
life sentences for murderers these are
things again that seem disconnected in a
time when we know that that we're having
more and more fentanyl drug overdoses
and more illegal immigrants why would
you make the border poorest which is
what he's argued for open border plus
sanctuary cities in pennsylvania so all
i've got to do is stand by these
realities and smile and they will
naturally gravitate to me but what i'm
going to do most importantly is reach
out to every corner of the state i'm in
philadelphia talking to urban
populations i'm talking to suburban
women groups that historically have
shied away from republican ideas saying
listen i love you guys i care about you
my policies will help you more now dr oz
won the primary after an endorsement
from former president trump who's under
a lot of scrutiny by the democrat lead
house committee investigating the
capital riot at yesterday's hearing gop
congresswoman liz chaney put the focus
on president trump's effort to overturn
the election by exerting pressure on
state officials and state legislatures
democrat adam schiff says that pressure
was a dangerous precursor to the
violence we saw on january 6 at the u.s
capitol but the former president still
insists the election was rigged and told
a rally in mississippi on saturday the
probe is fake and phony we call it the
insurrection hoax it's a hoax because it
was not an insurrection dr oz like most
republicans isn't paying much attention
well january 6th
there were criminal actions in january 6
and there's a legal system and i believe
in that legal system's ability to
prosecute appropriately people who broke
the law and they should pay the price if
you didn't break the law you shouldn't
i'd love to see that level of
interrogation into what went down
january 6th okay but i'll tell you when
you're out campaigning every day as i do
this is not top of mind for
pennsylvanians whether they're democrats
or liberals i mean i'm sure there are
people who are captivated by this but
they are worried that they can't go on
vacation 70 of pennsylvanians are
changing vacation plans because of
energy prices they're frustrated that
they can't have their communities thrive
because of ideological issues that block
energy which they know as natural gas
for example able to be cleanly harvested
from the ground and build value in their
communities these are all issues that
they're that's what they're thinking
about okay so no one's asked you about
the former president and the last year's
riot his involvement none of that i get
asked about it all the time on media
okay very rarely when i'm sitting in a
diner so people like me are the only
ones talking to you about it well it
does and i'm sure people are thinking
about it it's just not the number one
thing they're thinking about what
they're really worried about are that
day's problems and again i'm talking
about what the typical conversation you
have when you're doing a town hall and
believe me i'm out there all the time
and i explicitly tried to get
people uh on the on the left and the
right together i mean again i'm talking
to union leaders they're not asking me
about january 6. they're saying what are
you doing to make sure that we have a
wage that we can you know raise our
families healthy with and build pay
taxes build our communities and what are
you going to do about make sure we have
jobs their existential fear is that by
shutting down the energy economy of
pennsylvania you'll cost them jobs
directly these are the building unions
for example but in addition you're going
to shut down manufacturing in
pennsylvania i was visiting a company
that that builds big distribution
centers for like walmarts of the world
they can't find diesel fuel it's not
about the price
but they actually can't find the fuel
now that is a whole different level of
crisis that means i actually have to lay
people off because we can't go to work
they're paying stipends to help them
drive to work they're not asking me
about these other issues about two from
that happened in 2020 especially because
i wasn't involved in it they're asking
me what are we going to do to deal with
the clear and present threat that
they're not going to be able to run
their businesses when you sit back
sometimes and reflect is it hard to
believe what you're dealing with right
now i mean you you were a doctor doing
well on television here you are in the
middle of a race half the people are
giving you an unfavorable rating it has
to feel different
my wife always wonders why this is so
maybe my prefrontal cortex is shaped
differently i i don't mind criticism
most of the aggressive criticism isn't
about me it's the person who's angry and
they have a right to be angry and they
direct their anger at me but that's okay
i could not have lived my life with the
blessings my family received from this
country remember my parents are
immigrants they were welcomed here my
father's a doctor he was recruited to
come to this country i could not have
lived my life having done as well as
i've been blessed to do not fighting to
make sure our country was healthy but
the silver baton my dad handed me in the
race of life i've got to make it just as
shiny for my kids and my grandkids i
think i speak for a lot of americans who
have woken up one too many days with the
sense that there's anxiety in the
country that's addressable and so i'm
gonna do everything i can to help there
are many i believe who don't realize
their voice is that important it does
have an influence say what you see
others will do the same if one person
puts their hands up they'll get shot we
all put our hands up can't shoot us all
dr mehmed oz republican nominee for
senate in pennsylvania thanks very much
for joining us god bless you
[Music]
this is colin reed with your fox news
commentary coming up last august the
bureau of reclamation which is within
the interior department issued its first
ever water shortage for the colorado
river 40 million people rely on that
river for much of their water supply the
bureau of reclamation warned this will
likely be an ongoing narrative due to
climate change and last week bureau
commissioner camille tooten told
congress that a huge reduction in water
use is now needed there's so much to
this that is unprecedented and that is
true
but unprecedented is now the reality and
the normal in which reclamation must
manage our systems a warmer drier west
is what we are seeing today the public
policy institute of california says the
colorado river supplies roughly a third
of all water for southern california
cities and suburbs as well as farms and
imperial in riverside counties southern
nevada including las vegas gets 90
percent of its water from the colorado
river in may the arizona republic
reported that the city of phoenix gets
40 percent of its water from the
colorado river and arizona farmers are
already suffering according to phil
beshaw ceo of arizona farm bureau
federation you're talking about
multi-generational farmers folks that
have had these farms in their in their
families for for many many years and
they're and they're concerned i would
anticipate additional resources being
needed to mitigate the impacts of the
drought and the cuts that we'll have to
take along the colorado river if those
cuts get deeper now lake mead the
nation's largest reservoir on the
colorado river is shockingly low the
intake valve is showing and when the
bureau of reclamation commissioner
announced the amount of cuts needed to
avoid catastrophe water officials were
concerned to say the least the
commissioner's announcement tuesday was
i think stunning to those of us who work
on and think about and depend on the
colorado river john fleck is writer in
residence at the utten center at the
university of new mexico school of law
that is a huge volume
of water that we need to reduce
and it's going to be really difficult to
get there but it's also this really
frank recognition
of how bad the situation is that we're
in how empty the reservoirs are you know
the combination of drought with warm
temperatures with climate change layered
on top of it we're reaching the breaking
point in our ability to use water and
sustain our communities here in the
whole southwestern united states
we actually have some visual evidence
right that intake valve at lake mead
like me being the country's largest
reservoir you can actually see it now
and we do know that there are lower
intake valves that have been created in
preparation of this because many saw it
coming
but lake mead dropping rapidly at 28
capacity lake powell's much lower as
well um and to be specific about the
amount of cuts the bureau is talking
about
the commissioner said two to four
million acre feet one acre foot is
roughly 326 000 gallons of water so when
you say that you're you were stunned
i can't even wrap my mind around that
amount i mean i'm thinking like an
ocean's worth
yeah it's so hard to make sense of it
you know how many olympic swimming pools
or
um but the bottom line is that we in the
western united states for a long time
have been living on
bonus water surplus water the extra
water in these reservoirs from wet
periods in the past and we can't do that
anymore and so to translate that into
the lives of people this means the
cities that depend on the colorado river
are just going to be browner we're going
to have fewer lawns and fewer trees and
the farm communities that depend on the
colorado river's water
there will be less irrigated land in
those farm communities there's just no
way around this we're using too much
water and we need to scale back and this
has been a problem for a long time but
climate change is making it worse
when they say 40 million people rely on
water from the colorado river
does that include farmers and and that's
not 40 million people their entire water
source is from the colorado river right
there's there are other sources
right so that's 40 million people who
get at least part of their water supply
from the colorado river so we can take
my community of albuquerque new mexico
as an example we have available water
from the rio grande
we have available water from groundwater
that we can pump out of the aquifer and
we have imported colorado river water
that we bring through a series of dams
and tunnels so when we lose our colorado
river supply and it's going to be very
scarce this year
we go to other sources of groundwater if
you're in a city like los angeles and
san diego you have water from a number
of sources the colorado river is one of
them but but this is 40 million people
in seven states in the united states and
two states in mexico and five million
acres of irrigated farmland across the
western united states and down into
mexico that depend for at least a part
of their supply on the colorado river
and remember all the other supplies that
we depend on
they're shrinking too
yeah exactly
i want to get into that and i want to
get into solutions in a minute but
fighting over water as a california
native you and i are both from southern
california
so we've paid attention to this you more
than i but it always seems sort of
mysterious or nebulous water politics
can make people's eyes glaze over unless
you're i guess watching chinatown maybe
but when we talk about sort of the the
pecking order right their 7.5 million
acre feet go to upper basin states like
wyoming colorado utah new mexico where
you are and the same amount goes to
arizona nevada and california 1.5
million acre feet goes to mexico but
within all of that there are like water
rights there's senior water rights
junior water rights california due to
negotiations over the years gets more of
this water than arizona does and so
those first cuts when we talk about
cutting
those first cuts go to like at least in
the lower basin um states go to arizona
right and and we're already hearing from
farmers about about that right
yeah so we have this very complex
pecking order for the distribution of
water so what we've seen because the
farm communities have the highest
priority rights but the urban
communities
have
for reliability of supply
what we've seen is these collaborative
relationships not really fighting i mean
there's some conflict involved but these
collaborative relationships where the
cities will compensate farm communities
for reducing their use you know cities
will help pay for more efficient
irrigation systems or pay a farmer to
follow a field meaning not plant
completely and that conserved water then
can ensure the reliability of the city's
supplies and you know in most cases the
city's uses are actually going down
right municipal water conservation in
the colorado river basin is an amazing
success story so it's not like the
cities are just hogging more and more
water everybody's using less it's just
that the available supply is going down
even faster right
john the bureau of reclamation
commissioner told congress last week
they are choosing right now to act as a
partner to states and water districts
and farms but they warned they could act
unilaterally
what does unilateral action at the
federal level
look like
first of all an important point we have
seen in the history of colorado river
basin governance over the last 20 years
this same pattern the federal government
has to threaten
and then the states fall into line and
come to an agreement and figure out how
to
share a shrinking water supply i expect
that to be what happens again this time
the federal government has a number of
legal
authorities that would allow them to
reduce the amount of water that they
release from lake mead for farms and
cities downstream they have the legal
authorities to do that they would prefer
not to but at some point
they're finding dead bodies in lake mead
it's low at some point the federal
government has to step in and be the
adult in the room and say you all are
not doing enough voluntarily we need to
protect the long-term viability of this
system with some more immediate and more
extreme short-term cuts than you all
have been willing to do voluntarily but
should the flip side of that be some
other solutions like if you're gonna
sign a bipartisan infrastructure law
should some of that money go to to
increasing water storage especially if
we're hearing that it's going to be less
snow more rain
should there be discussions about
alternative solutions like what should
the discussion be in terms of solutions
going forward
sure i would say all of the above we are
going to spend money to build decel
plants
along the coast more of them than we've
ever done before
we are going to build in cases where it
makes sense more storage
we are going to get better at
storing water underground spreading
storm water we're going to do all of
those things
but that doesn't
yield enough water
to solve the real problem
and there's a bunch of money in the
infrastructure bill to work at some of
those problems but the scale of the
shortfall of water in this system
on the colorado river here in the rio
grande
those shortfalls are so great that there
is no
concrete and pipe fix for it it's about
using less water ultimately using less
water even some who know to do this and
have done it successfully before
struggle just this year californians
increase their water use at one point
despite pleas to cut and it's on the
minds of water educators like laura
ramos at the california water institute
at fresno state university you know i
think people are still learning what a
mega drought means what it means to be
in a drought and what it means and how
it affects you
or you as an individual because the
drought is affecting the environment
agriculture and communities and so when
the governor says reduce water i don't
know that everybody in a home knows how
much water they really use and what is
it um
you know i i know that i turn on my
dishwasher and i know that i do this
many loads of laundry and this is how
much water i put in my grass but i don't
know that everybody knows exactly how
much that means
so to them they could be thinking that
they are reducing the amount of water
usage but in the total it might not be
so i think it might take a couple of
months for people to realize how much
water we use on a day-to-day basis there
are other sources there are other
solutions but it's not going to be one
solution it's going to have to because
the drought is so big and it's affecting
so many different areas it's going to
have to be a plethora or a buffet of all
of the different solutions
it's going to take water treatment
plants this new infrastructure it's just
not going to be one one solution but
also um including in some of those
solutions is not just the infrastructure
and the tangible things but the working
together
between all of the different
stakeholders that use that water so it
is farmers working with communities
working with
legislatures working with environmental
advocates and all of them coming
together so that we can say it's one
water and not just water for ag or water
for people it is water for california
water for
the united states it's water for
everybody and
learning to work together
to divide that pie or work together
towards solutions
but are you hearing policy-wise of
anything concrete like so what when you
think of like concrete policy solutions
that are happening right now or that are
being talked about right now are there
any
yes there are um there are actually some
you mentioned earlier subsidence are
that the land is um shrinking or sliding
down due to groundwater recharge there
are two points in our biggest canals the
delta mendota and the frank kern canal
that have what we call pinch points so
the canals move water through gravity
but if the ground in a higher end sinks
now the angle at which that water moves
is no longer there and so those canals
are not able to move as much water as
they were meant to and so there is
current legislation and funding to fix
some of those pinch points in the canals
because they were only moving i think 50
or 60 percent of the water they were
made for so there are some that are
going to help short term and then there
is need for
term solutions
laura ramos thank you so much for your
time
thank you
[Music]
and in other news i'm gianna gelosi
millennials get a lot of slack for a lot
of different things one is the fact that
they choose pets over parenthood and
homeownership and a new study is showing
just how deep those routes run a recent
study by consumer affairs surveyed one
thousand pet owners and found that 57
percent of participants aged 27 to 42
love their furry friends more than their
sibling half of respondents say they
love their pets more than their mom
boyfriends and girlfriends don't even
stand a chance millennials romantic
partners come in second to a pet for
about 30 percent of the people that were
asked according to the survey
millennials make up the biggest share of
pet owners in the u.s and spend more
money on their animals than any other
age group one in four millennials said
they would be willing to even sell their
car to afford a life-saving procedure
for their pet now we already established
that millennials like myself are not as
much interested in home ownership but
we're going to speak in hypotheticals
right now so if you were looking for a
pet friendly state for you and your
furry beloved maine is the most
pet-friendly state in the country new
york is the least maybe some helpful
information for the 75 percent of
millennials and 89 percent of gen z folk
who say they are influenced by their
pets needs when choosing a place to live
for the fox news rundown i'm gianna
delosi
[Music]
from the fox news podcasts network in
these ever-changing times you can rely
on fox news for hourly updates for the
very latest news and information on your
time listen and download now at
foxnewspodcast.com or wherever you get
your favorite podcasts
rate and review the fox news rundown on
apple podcasts or wherever you listen
it's time for your fox news commentary
colin reid
what's on your mind like tsunamis in the
ocean political tidal waves form after a
seismic interruption something there has
been no shortage of in joe biden's
america
it's ironic for the man who promised a
return to normalcy
on biden's watch words like inflation
and supply chain have gone from esoteric
terms and academic textbooks to daily
problems around kitchen tables
everyday necessities have become
unaffordable or unavailable against that
backdrop voters will head to the polls
in less than five months to render
judgment on the byte administration
the first midterm is never fun for the
party in charge but this one looks like
a five alarm fire here are five reasons
why
first biden's support among hispanics a
voting block he carried by a two to one
margin in 2020 is cratering while this
trend isn't new a quinnipiac university
poll earlier this spring showed his
approval rating among hispanics at just
26 percent with illegal border crossing
apprehensions hitting new all-time highs
turns out voters are looking for a new
direction
second gas prices are soaring the
administration is out of answers and no
relief is in sight it would be a
politically deadly combination heading
into any summer driving season even more
so for a country yearning to travel post
lockdown instead of solutions biden and
crew continued to borrow a page from the
elizabeth warren playbook by demonizing
the private sector third the inflation
biden and crew dismissed as transitory
has come roaring back on the heels of
last week's 8.6 uptick the federal
reserve announced its most aggressive
interest rate hike in nearly three
decades
remarkably biden remains in denial about
inflation dismissing concerns as quote
lies about reckless spending
fourth biden has lost the ability to
scare voters his dire warnings about
maga republicans do not pack a punch
when the stock market has shed 11
trillion dollars and taken retirement
accounts with them
finally and perhaps worst of all doubts
about biden's age and ability are no
longer related to his partisan critics
even his fellow democrats are openly
amusing about the next chapter
stating the obvious former obama advisor
david axelrod raised eyebrows when he
described biden's age as quote a major
issue the embattled white house press
office is already fending off questions
about biden's re-election prospects
the succession jostling has already
begun which ironically may be biden's
saving grace
any list of would-be standard-bearers
consists of the retreads democratic
senators you amy klobuchar and cory
booker the extremes like u.s senators
warren and bernie sanders representative
alexandria ocasio-cortez or those
associated with the failures of the
current administration
such as vice president and border czar
kamala harris or transportation
secretary and supply chain guru p buda
judge
for all the inks filled in the future of
the gop it turns out the democrat bench
is utterly devoid of talent that's not
exactly a compelling message to carry
into battle but it might be biden's bet
to shore up support from wavering
democrats i'm the only chance you've got
less than halfway through his first term
the man who came into office having
received the most votes in history and
relishing comparisons to fdr and lbj is
a walking lame duck and that's before
the political tidal wave hits the shore
i'm colin reed a republican strategist
former campaign manager for
massachusetts senator scott brown and
co-founder of south and hill strategies
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com and for up to the
minute news go to foxnews.com
[Music]
jason in the house the jason chaffetz
podcast dive deeper than the headlines
in the party lines as i take on american
life politics and entertainment
subscribe now on
foxnewspodcast.com or wherever you
download podcasts
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust and click the fox news rundown
playlist for the latest episodes